JEREMY WALKER: Welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have special guests Vidyard
here today, all the way from
Waterloo, Canada.
We actually have
Cody and Tyler.
Say hi, guys.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE:
Hey, I'm Tyler.
CODY WRIGHT: I'm Cody.
JEREMY WALKER: And they were
nice enough to join us.
So if you haven't heard of
Vidyard, it's actually a video
player for marketers.
And rather than talk through
it too much, I thought we'd
just dive into the history
and then we'll go
right into a demo.
So why don't you guys tell us a
little bit about the history
of Vidyard, how it came about
and the product itself, and
then we'll go into
a nice demo?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Sure.
So Vidyard actually started
out as a company that was
producing minute-long
explainer-type videos for companies.
And we would give these
videos to our clients.
And then they'd ask us, so what
do we do with the video
now that we have it?
And so from that we grew into
making a platform that
[INAUDIBLE]
the answer for what to do with
you video afterwards.
And that means giving them the
tools to analyze how their
video is doing, how much
people are watching it.
As well as integrated into all
sorts of other platforms that
share the video analytics
with them.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
That's kind of funny.
So you're making the video
marketing stuff first, and
then they were like well,
what do we do with it?
So you built a player
tool for them?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Exactly.
JEREMY WALKER: Awesome.
Great.
Well, let's jump
into the demo.
I had a couple questions because
I know some people
aren't quite sure what that
means to have a video player
for marketers.
But it's pretty clear once
you see the demo.
So why don't we jump
into that?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Sure.
So I'll just take
over the screen.
So here's just the main
dashboard of our platform with
a very simple analytics view
here, different things for
your account wide.
So if I hop inside of a specific
player here, in here
you'll have all sorts of tools
for creating stuff like a call
to action at the end
of your video.
So it's got a simple builder
where you can set up a form so
that you can capture
people's emails.
JEREMY WALKER: I saw
this on your demo.
It's a pretty nice feature.
Basically it comes out the side
and asks for information.
It's not too intrusive.
It was kind of a nice feature.
I can see how marketers would
really love that.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE:
Yeah, exactly.
So we're all about giving
marketers these sorts of tools
to do what they need to do.
As well as from that, there's an
A/B split testing area for
your slash screens.
And here you can see the one
that we have set up on our
homepage right now, which is
using these two thumbnails.
Are then we give the analytics
for each of those three
thumbnails.
And you can see that the
one is at almost 10%
clickthrough rate.
Meanwhile, the other two
are more on 7-1/2%.
So right now we have a clear
winner of which one's the best
out of those three.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, this is a
really neat feature I liked in
your product.
So a thumbnail really does
impact clickthrough rate.
So like they said, what they did
is they basically take a
bunch, let you set up a bunch,
and you even let them set up
their percentage for when
it shows up, right?
Like, 10% here, 20% on this one,
so then you can get an
idea of the clickthrough
rate, right?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Oh, yeah.
You can fully distribute
it however you want.
So if you have one that you
think won't do that well but
you want to try it anyway, you
can give it a very small
percent so that it doesn't
influence the overall traffic
all that much but you can still
test how well it does.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
And you guys were talking
a little bit about
general best practices.
So I know from what you were
saying, it really is different
depending on the scenario.
But at least for a general side
you were saying something
about there's a difference
between if it's not front and
center and it's off
to the side.
Would you mind telling
the audience a
little bit about that?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: For sure.
So if you have a smaller player
off to the side of a
page, then it makes much more
sense to have a thumbnail
that's brighter and
stands out more.
Because that way people will
actually notice it off to the
side and then click
it and watch it.
Versus if it's something big
and center in the page
already, then you want something
more engaging and
personable so that they're more
curious as to what that
could be and that would lead
them to actually watching it.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
And you guys were a
little surprised
with this one, right?
The guy on the beach ended
up doing the best.
Did you think one of
the other ones
would be a winner instead?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Yeah.
I think we thought the one
with the girl on the
sandcastle and the dog would be
better, because that's more
things going on.
But I guess people like
the guy on the beach.
JEREMY WALKER: So the important
thing is general
practices we went over.
But if you're going to test it,
even ones that you don't
think will win may end
up doing really well.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: It depends
entirely on your audience and
what they like or don't like.
And that's the point of
A/B split testing is
to figure that out.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, you guys do a lot of
analytics as well to help
these marketers out, right?
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Yeah.
So we have a whole page
dedicated to that Analytics
Center, which gives a very
easy way to view all your
general views, devices and
browsers, where your videos
are being embedded, geography.
As well as all of these graphs
can then be further limited by
the actual player so we can get
that home page, narrow it
down from there.
So it's all about just giving
marketers all the information
and all the statistics they
need to make the decisions
they need to make.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And one thing I like about you
guys is you really want
marketers to get the most
bang for their buck.
So you allow them to export to
YouTube, and then you pull all
the analytics from there so that
they can have their own
customized player on
their own page.
But then they push that content
out to YouTube to get
more views.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE:
Yeah, exactly.
Because YouTube is such an
invaluable force of people.
So we are always going to fully
support pushing your
video to YouTube.
So the general flow for that
is upload to Vidyard.
Then we can do all sorts of our
more advanced analytics,
but then push that video to
your YouTube channels and
market it through
there as well.
And then here in the Analytics
Center, you can see how well
it's doing and compare
it to how it's doing
on your home page.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Thanks for giving us that little
taste of the product.
And obviously you can see a more
detailed demo of things
on their site, vidyard.com.
Why don't we talk a little bit
about the technical section?
So I wanted you to talk for
the developers out there.
How did you implement this?
And what programming language
did you use and why?
CODY WRIGHT: [INAUDIBLE]
Ruby, but as a Sinatra
application instead.
And so we haven't
mixed this up.
It'll interact with YouTube
[INAUDIBLE] working in Ruby
and also working in Sinatra
through the Google API client
[INAUDIBLE].
And we're running data through
the D3 Data API, as well as
[INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
You cut off there
for a second.
I think you said you
were using Ruby?
CODY WRIGHT: Yeah.
We're Ruby with some Rails,
as well as a Sinatra
application as well.
And interfaced with the Google
stuff through the Google API
client [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And it sounds like you guys
are already using the new
version 3.0 of the Data API?
CODY WRIGHT: Correct.
Yes, we are.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Thumbs up.
CODY WRIGHT: Yeah, we made a
switch about four months.
Before we were using another
RubyGem that did most of the
YouTube stuff for us.
We just decided to write our
own stuff that does more
specific the type of thing
you can do with YouTube.
And it's gone really
well thus far.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Especially
the analytics.
Because D3 is much better at
being able to break down by
geography and stuff like that.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, our new
Analytics API is pretty
helpful, rather than
the large zip file.
So was there anything that
came that surprised you a
little bit when you
were integrating
with the YouTube APIs?
CODY WRIGHT: The only thing that
we've been a little bit
surprised by is the way the
tokens work. and sometimes
getting tokens that expired.
But beyond that, the guides are
really helpful and it's
worked out really well for us.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, any features you'd like
to see in the product in the
near future?
CODY WRIGHT: The only thing
that we've had a lot of
clients ask for and we haven't
been able to do is uploading
and choosing custom thumbnails
on YouTube through the API.
Now I know that's available to
content providers, but you
can't do it for just
general users.
And that's something we get
asked for all the time.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, we do
have the video thing.
We're opening that up more,
so keep an eye on that.
But as you said, we do have one
right now, we're just a
little bit limited for access.
Well, great.
Any other thing you'd tell a
developer that's getting
started with the APIs?
CODY WRIGHT: No.
I think just looking through
that YouTube API doc site is
really good.
And there's some good code
examples on there, and it
seems to work really well.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Definitely
Stack Overflow's a very good
resource, and you guys are
very active on it.
So any questions you have,
just go to Stack
Overflow and ask.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
definitely.
We do have a keyword
YouTube-API.
My team actually monitors
that, so make sure
you check it out.
Great.
Well, I think that wraps
up our show.
As always, we're always looking
to hire if you're
interested in developer
relations.
Check out
developers.google.com/jobs.
We have some openings,
so check it out.
And a big thanks to Vidyard
for coming all the way
virtually from Waterloo,
and jumping on to
hang out with us.
Again, check out Vidyard.com and
their new video, the one
with the guy on the beach.
I actually watched it,
it's pretty funny.
So check it out.
And thanks again guys
for joining us.
And we'll see you next week.
TYLER CAMPAIGNE: Good.
Thanks for having us.
CODY WRIGHT: Thank you.
JEREMY WALKER: Thanks.